مناوشات تغريده وتصريحات يبداها ايلين
ماسك بين الفينه والاخرى منذ ان اصبح
الطائر الازرق من ممتلكاته
تغييرات جذريه اجرها ماسك في سياسه الشركه
تبدو ذات ايقاع سريع لم يناسب الموظفين
والمستخدمين تداعيتها تبدو اوضح يوما بعد
يوم اخرها الحرب المصغره التي جرت بين
ماسك وشركه ابل التي اوقفت اعلاناتها على
تويتر خوفا من الخطط الجديده التي يعدها
ماسك بخصوص المحتوى وتحديدا من تحولها الى
منصه للمعلومات المغلوطه وخطاب الكراهيه
الملياردير الامريكي اتهم عملاقه
تكنولوجيا بالوقوف ضد حريه التعبير مغردا
عبر منصته
ومتخوفا من فقدانها في البلاد تغيرات في
المضمون يراه ماسك في مصلحه حريه التعبير
بينما تنظر اليها شركات الاعلان طريقه
لنشر المعلومات المظله وخطاب الكراهيه من
قبل بعض المستخدمين ما ادى الى النزوح
جماعيا للاعلانات عن المنصه ليدخل البيت
الابيض على خط الاسماء مؤكدا على ضروره
مراقبه من الصون ونشاطها الجديد
من المعلومات الخاطئه والكراهيه التي
نراها ويجب عليها اتخاذ الاجراءات ونحن
نراقب وضع تويتر الان عن كسب
انسحابات بجمله يقوم بها المعلنون كما
المستخدمون قد تؤدي الى خسائر ماليه هائله
في تويتر الا ان ازمه المحتوى التي فقها
ماسك قد لا تقتصر على الخسائر الماديه بل
تتجاوز ذلك الى التهديدات لايقاف التطبيق
على متاجر الهواتف الذكيه والتي هددت بها
ابل لكن الحل السحري السهل كان لدى ماسك
وهو انتاج هواتف جديده الى عمر العربيه